this already feels like a terrible idea
hey there I'm Aria and I truly believe
that one man's trash is another man's
treasure so today I'm challenging three
of my most creative friends to make the
best use of some of my old junk see
through a very handy crafty creative
individuals so today I would like to
challenge you to use your uniquely
creative minds to make me your very very
best
the umbrella oh okay all the things it's
expecting you to say an umbrella
mmm we've got a Walgreens down the
street we can run right down give you a
dollar and you could go buy an umbrella
but that means nothing to me tomorrow I
wanted something that you handcrafted
lovingly for me when I whip this out in
Seattle Washington I can say I will
think of you when the rain comes down on
me well hopefully it won't because if
the umbrella works exactly there is a
catch this umbrella that you will put
together for me can only be made using
the very items inside of you what where
why what is this where is this my trunk
mostly and your umbrella that should
make for me will be judged on two
factors firstly its aesthetic beauty
the second factor your being judged on
is functionality okay this is a
challenge for sure the time you have to
make your umbrella 60 minutes which
begins right so as far as my craft
background goes I have two nieces and
two nephews I spend a lot of time with
them when I can and I think I've kind of
found my love for crafting again through
them yeah I'm excited to kind of be a
six-year-old again I just kind of like
do crafts in my house I like to decorate
my room with like DIY stuff so I made a
terrarium out of a TV and a neon light
which is really cool
I also made this cloud light that sits
in my room so it hangs out and like it
just looks like a cloud it's like
thundering it like I'm a really big
crafter like an embarrassing amount fun
projects I like to do on the side I redo
furniture
I also was a seamstress in college
I really really want to try to win by
making the umbrella open and close so I
got this crutch if I can get this crutch
to come apart it would be great to use
this feature as an opening and closing
function oh that's not a promising yes
okay decoration is where I think I'm
gonna be most troubled I want to keep it
simple I don't think I'm gonna do a lot
of extra stuff I really want to woo baby
it's time this has got to be the rod
there's just no way I'm not using this I
have a survivalist brain so like when in
doubt in that last minute when the
pressure is on I'm gonna make sure there
is an umbrella this I've got this as
long as I've got this I feel good I'm
just debating how wide I want to make it
to like stop the rain thinking like 10
inches we may go a little bit longer I
was gonna go for it the big beach ball
girl was so very fast and she had it so
instead I grabbed up this sheet Aria he
is a really fashionable guy he did say
part of this was aesthetics was more
aesthetic than a hat umbrella I'm going
a little outside of the box than what
was actually described in the challenge
and that may work for me or a made
completely backfire and look like oh
it's in Space Jam where Bill Murray
wears one of these I don't want it to
look like that math involved in this I
don't want to do know any of the math
[Music]
it's time to pop this beach ball I
actually hate popping from a scale it
won't like noise oh yeah what smells so
weird on the inside its breath air oh
I'm already planning on scaling back
that's it
do not do this at home do not hold
scissors like this if my nieces and
nephews are watching don't do what your
aunt is doing right now I just need to
attach the top of the umbrella to this
in a way where it'll close I am
confident that if nothing else it'll be
an adjustable umbrella and that's still
cool oh can I use hot glue with this is
it a risk yeah it'll be fine I mean
mostly I just want Aria to have to walk
down the street using this thing like
that's the biggest draw to me yeah you
guys are planning I'm just flying by the
seat of my pants
you're free-forming I bet that's how the
first umbrella was made no someone just
kind of like going for it oh what a
treat this is wow this whole time I've
been lurking Wow you guys look like
you're doing a phenomenal job
it's definitely been a work in progress
what's the theme here Ryan so this is
just the the structure of it like no
design yet I used a crutch and broke it
apart so it could be adjustable so
though you can adjust
I wanted to make recipe Connie Wow that
actually has the shape of an umbrella
wow you guys are impressing you anata mo
yet but you two are the presidents so
much as everybody knows aria when they
see you they think fashion icon hmm so
that's my goal right now is to really
give
a statement piece that lives up to you
it's gonna be tough that's fantastic
because I want to be able to go through
Milan Italy with this umbrella
Merl this is uh it's quite something aha
yeah it's it's words what are the words
that are coming to mind the is this a
trash bag of several trash bags a simple
trash bags when I decorate it you're
decorating it oh yeah of course that's
done oh thank god I'm gonna rise like a
phoenix out of the ashes
alright everyone we have 30 minutes left
good luck I believe in all of you yeah
yeah all right time is up
Wow guns down this was a wild ride I was
definitely very nervous to begin because
it seems like the other two have a lot
more crafting experience however I will
say once I kind of let it go and was
like you know what you're not gonna die
if you don't win this competition I was
like I'm gonna have some fun this I feel
like really embody is what I'm trying to
do put out on the town out to have a
good time I would be proud walking
around with this umbrella this is my
umbrella I went in very confident
probably overly confident I made this to
where it could be functional I started
it where you could like slide it oh my
god did I just break my own Braille no
okay
holy fudge so really it's a secret
weapon but also it's an extendable
umbrella so that way if you like you're
shorter you can bring it closer to you I
mean not a lot there's only like six
inches here I think are you'll like it
and I do feel like it is gonna be very
functional it's a wide rim and a flick
it'll make you and
as you can see there are clear panels so
we can see whatever is going on under
here we can catch the eye of whoever is
around us we also have the emoji that we
all know and love it's fashionable I
feel like we're going for style we may
look like Bill Murray from Space Jam but
I think it a cool wig well you guys have
done a really great job but let's now go
out and test the actual functionality of
your umbrellas how exactly are we gonna
test these funny you should ask all
right Connie you work hard on this
umbrella now let's see it in action
I have a lot of Eve in it I am wearing
not waterproof makeup so I've got my
fingers crossed for you Connie this
already feels like a terrible idea
[Music]
she's dry she's dry all right Ryan so
I'm ready I'm not worried about getting
wet oh so really does yeah
I mean I can feel the water on the back
of me only because it feels like it's
rolling down but in general I feel dry
you're free beep her head like you're in
Milan Italy for me I really did I really
I'm nervous right it's just like I'm
just gonna fall you got it you're doing
amazing sweetie
well great job everyone
let's head back inside and I'll be
choosing my new umbrella oh yes now it's
just a moment of truth Connie that was
very impressive when I saw you making it
I was confused as to why there wasn't a
handle but then on Genuity I've never
seen that before have you seen this
seminal classic Space Jam ah so you Bill
Murray
he's very fashionable just like you your
nose is so Brown setec Lee it is clean
it's simple functionality it worked like
a charm
all right Merle yeah what can I say
about Merle this the more I look at it I
think art piece maybe I want people to
see me at this
you might be insane but it looks good
functionality you know it wasn't bad
your feet got quite wet sure Ryan this
is quite something
it has a Christmas vibe which I love
aesthetics fantastic you know now the
actual functionality of it it did great
it withstood the rain you got a little
bit on your back but you that you're
holding it for fashion purposes thus a
little bit of rain on the on the back
but on the back but on the black well
now he winds feel like I might be docked
because it's not holding functionality
like look at this all right I love
winning just as much as the next person
but I feel like it's not me it is not
you it's gonna have to be Connie Connie
I would love to put this on will you
right so so just to be clear I've won
this round so it's one to zero
I'll be ready next time
[Music]
you